[Applause]
we're going into the third wave already
very very exhausted and tired we are
losing staff and that's going to be the
biggest challenge
[Applause]
you can have capacity what if you don't
have nurses
what if you don't have doctors this is
the scene
inside toronto's humber river hospital
in the throes of the third wave
of the pandemic icu beds are full
patients are younger and sicker and the
staff
are being pushed to their limits i'm
very concerned where we're headed our
capacity to
continue on like this the pandemic has
taken such a toll on health care workers
that some are leaving the profession
they once loved and dedicated their
lives to
and as cases of coven 19 swell again
straining hospitals across the country
the staff that are left are tired and
struggling to keep up
at the beginning of the pandemic
everybody was ready and willing i
remember getting so many emails saying
hey i'm ready to come in i'm ready to
come and help
i don't get any emails like that anymore
dr nisha bakshi is the internal medicine
lead at the royal alexandra hospital in
edmonton
she's also in charge of the hospital's
kovud response
everybody's tired of it it's exhausting
to work on the kova unit
you are there for a 10 hour shift you
know you're wearing your full ppe
right now i think that we're seeing so
many young patients come in
that it's also there's some moral injury
and emotional burnout
so just finishing up um shift today on
the kovid unit
we're starting to see our
hospitalizations climb steadily
we're tired we're battle worn but we
will continue to show up
dr bakshi actually holds the record for
the most days spent on the covid ward at
her hospital
it's come at a cost it's come at a
mental health cost as a physical cost
within the medical field and
particularly with physicians
i think it's still viewed as a sign of
weakness that if i admit that i'm
depressed
or anxious or have ptsd it must mean
that i cannot do my job
in january dr bakshi who's also a mother
of two young children
was diagnosed with post-traumatic stress
disorder or ptsd
it's a mental health condition that can
occur after a person
experiences or witnesses a traumatic
event and so december i describe it as
chaos
it was it was just chaos there was new
patients
all the time there were patients
crashing all the time
and i noticed that i was having
difficulty sleeping i was having a lot
of nightmares
i was reliving and replaying
conversations i had with families i
think that was probably the
the biggest thing that hit me i didn't
care if i showed up or not
and i knew that that was not like me but
i think what really did it was my
husband my husband said to me he said
you're not yourself
you know you're you're angry you're
taking things out on us
and i know that you've been through a
lot and maybe it's time to get some help
and and that was it she got help and has
been seeing a counselor
since i'm a pretty resilient person i
have i think
fantastic coping skills but even myself
i was tested i was put at a limit that i
couldn't
sustain and it's not just physicians who
are experiencing this
the vast majority of all healthcare
workers reported worsening mental health
during the pandemic
according to statistics canada and among
workers who had direct contact with
patients who may be sick with kovid
that number is even higher there's
always a nurse there and that's pretty
unique to our profession like 24
7 day and night 365 if you're in a
hospital
a nurse is there nurses provide the bulk
and the majority of patient care
denika mcpherson has worked as an icu
nurse in toronto for eight years
right now she's treating patients with
covet 19
while also studying to become a nurse
practitioner as you step into a covered
positive room i can't
i don't even know how to describe that
to somebody you just have this
like silent prayer that you you throw up
to the god and you're like i hope this
ppe is work on properly and working
and then you just walk in that room and
you just have to trust that everything
is fine
even before the pandemic nurse's stress
levels and workloads were high
a 2019 canadian study found that nurses
experience widespread and severe
symptoms of ptsd
anxiety depression burnout and suicidal
behavior
at a rate higher than the general
population and now
the pandemic has exacerbated things
workloads have increased
and nurses are being pushed to their
breaking point you feel like
tired and depleted and you're just
wondering when the end is coming like is
it going to come
brigade umagba is also an icu nurse
she says she's exhausted and burnt out
and it's starting to impact her
relationship with her nine-year-old
daughter
i just feel this weakness and um a lot
of times i can't even play with her
like i'm tired i need to recover my feet
hurts my legs hurt my muscles hurt my
neck hurts so everywhere hurts
it's more it's more like a chronic
situation at this point
but i'm just really mentally drained
berget says a month ago
she started having nightmares and
trouble sleeping
and she says it's not just her her
colleagues are experiencing
the same thing the amount of dead people
we see right and also
the cold blues the chaos is really
affecting a lot of people
she says more needs to be done for
nurses reduced workloads
counseling increasing pay and wages and
stronger public health measures
would give nurses incentives to stay we
we also
think that this could have been avoided
so with all of that it's just put so
much burden on us
and and people are asking what's the
point
the turnover of nurses was a major
problem before the pandemic
it's estimated one in five nurses left
the profession
every year and the pandemic has
accelerated this
we we joke and say we wish we could
split ourselves into like two or three
people to get our work done but it's
it's not possible
it's very hard to stay in a profession
where you have very hard workloads and
you're
feeling that ethical or moral distress
that you're not
able to deliver optimal or the best care
and as hospitals across the country ramp
up their capacity
adding new icu beds to deal with the
latest surge of covet cases
some provinces like hard hit ontario are
searching for thousands of nurses
there's also a shortage of personal
support workers
it's rampant right now a lot of psw's
are leaving the field
a field that we once loved and dedicated
our lives to
sharon tanner clarkson has been a psw
for nearly a decade
she works in palliative care in toronto
she kept going to work
amid covet outbreaks and scares
colleagues getting sick
daily stress and constant rule changes
she showed up until she couldn't she's
now off on stress leave without pay
it's been really emotional there's been
days where you spend time
in your car at lunch just to get your
mask off
and you're crying because you're totally
frustrated was there a final straw for
you
a moment where you thought i just can't
do it anymore
there was my last day
before i went off on my leave and i
felt like the walls were caving in we
were
short staffed i left in tears that day
absolute tears bawling and just walked
right out you know i've pretty broad
shoulders i've been doing
this type of work for a very long time
but this whole
pandemic and this whole situation has
just really
broke me do you think you'll go back to
work sadly
um i may not go back
to what i was once doing and loving
where are you seeing the most shortages
everywhere
if we don't really address health human
resource situation
our system is going to fall apart
abby sriharin is a professor at the
university of toronto
who studies burnout in the medical field
so the studies
pre-pandemic have shown 50 to 60 percent
of
health workforce was experiencing
burnout but the pandemic has actually
increased that rate although burnout
itself is not technically a medical
condition
it can cause depression anxiety and
fatigue
which can lead to feelings of numbness
anger and guilt
physically it can cause high cholesterol
diabetes heart disease
and various other illnesses that can
shorten a person's lifespan
so people go on stress leaves right and
you are now not in that environment
that's triggering the stress and burnout
so you will feel better you go back and
it's going to happen again
unless we address the working conditions
and how
our people are compensated and what type
of
incentives are there to keep them in the
workforce
we are not going to see any changes
in every facet of canada's healthcare
system people are leaving their jobs
others are sticking it out until the end
of the pandemic out of loyalty for their
colleagues and patients
but as soon as it's over some say
they'll also walk away
the fear is there could be a mass exodus
among canada's healthcare workers
impacting the entire system for years to
come
how worried are you about hospitals
capacity to treat people during the
third wave
and into the future acutely right now
i'm very worried and i don't think we're
going to be able to ignore all the
non-cloven patients coming in they're
very sick they're going to need care
and that's going to translate into a
system that cannot keep up
it's been more than a year of showing up
when they were called
working long hours in ppe until their
whole body ate
setting up video calls so families can
say final goodbyes
they cried with them slept a few hours
and did it all over again
and now with no end in sight how will
they manage this punishing third wave
it's no secret that healthcare workers
are resilient does that make you hopeful
it does it also makes me feel sad
because i think there's an expectation
that we are resilient
and it comes back to that stigma of
mental health
in medicine that you know this is what
we were trained for we deal with life
and death but
i think that there there is a limit to
how much we should be expecting from
healthcare workers
because right now i can tell you that
most people are not resilient
most people are still just surviving i
think resiliency is probably at an
all-time low